lieutenant colonel in the u.s army
reserves and former hawaii congresswoman
tulsi gabbard aloha tulsi um i always
love i always say aloha and i know it
might be grating for some people i do it
because i love hawaii i go there often
it feels natural to me but there's
something that i'd like you to talk
about a bit because it means something
it's not just a greeting it's it's a
it's it means something about how we
behave towards other people and i think
you really deeply
understand that and conveyed that with
your reaction to these results so i'd
love you to just tell us tell us in at
more length how you feel
uh thank you steve first of all it's
impossible to say aloha without smiling
and bringing a smile to someone else's
face and there's a reason for that
because it's a it has a very deep and
powerful meaning in that when you greet
someone with aloha you're saying i
recognize that we are all children of
god we are all brothers and sisters
we're all connected and i come to you
with respect and love and care and
that's really what what it comes down to
is is everyone wants to be happy
and so it's no wonder that we find
ourselves in a place where we are
miserable and we are stressed out and
frustrated when it seems like everywhere
we turn we see politicians social media
mainstream media fomenting fear and
anger hatred divisiveness racializing
everything so when we have leaders who
step forward who sincerely want to do
what's right for the people who care and
treat us with respect allowing the light
of god's love to shine through
this is where we see there is cause for
hope and optimism and the ability for us
to come together as a people to move
forward
exactly and and i just want to put i
mean just to put this up on screen it
was the exact opposite of what you
you're talking about uh but i think it's
important i'd love your response it's
such an important thing for everyone to
see that this is the way some democrats
speak this is corey bush okay
representative cory bush speaking about
a disagreement with joe manchin her
colleague
um on the spending bill this is how she
put it joe manchin's opposition to the
build back better act is anti-black
anti-child anti-woman and anti-immigrant
i saw that i thought honestly like you
can have legitimate disagreements over
policy you can and and so i want
everyone to understand that what you're
talking about is not some kumbaya
everyone's just get along and we don't
disagree of course we disagree politics
is about disagreement and who's got the
best plan and so on but you don't have
to do it like that to call someone who
you disagree anti-black anti-war i just
couldn't believe that
it it really just shows again that this
is a symptom of a deeper
um
a lack of a spiritual foundation steve
where if if you're not able to see
someone regardless of party politics
regardless of your position whether you
agree or disagree if you're not able to
see another person
as a child of god as someone that you
can respect at that fundamental level as
a as a fellow american then this is
where we see all of this darkness
coming from and so it's no wonder as you
were talking about the results in
virginia
that people
chose to respond positively towards that
message of hope and optimism for our
future that message of coming together
that message of care and respect for all
people
and and this is again this is where this
is where i find hope uh for our future
uh if we go back to those fundamental
values and principles of who we really
are uh then this is this is how we can
come together and and it's just the last
quick point chelsea is just the way that
um you know we have to engage with each
other on the basis of good faith just
you say okay i don't agree with what
you're saying but it's not because i
think you're a bad person i just don't
think you're going about it the right
way
and have the conversation
i think it's important at a time like
this to remember the words of patrick
henry
in the federalist papers he said let us
trust god and our better judgment to set
us right hereafter united we stand
divided we fall let us not split into
factions which must destroy that union
upon which our existence hangs
we have to be able to come together
recognizing what's at stake
the peril peril of our future if we
don't come together exactly beautifully
put i really appreciate
what you had to say this week and it was
great to see you tonight tassie see you
soon hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else